magic is something that we commonly see
through all types of fiction and works
of fantasy most of the time it provides
us with a major plot device it allows us
to submerge ourselves in a world that
feels familiar but yet unique and
fantastical in works of fantasy and
fiction it's common to see magic
described as light and dark good and
evil there are acceptable practices and
then those that are taboo the subject of
this video is necromancy a practice that
many classify as black magic or dark
witchcraft a school of magic that should
not be practiced but that wasn't always
the case and so today we'll take a look
at some of the origins of necromancy how
it evolved and what examples we have
today before we go any further we first
need to define necromancy the term
itself refers to a practice of magic
that centers around communicating with
the dead this can involve someone in
their spirit or even raising their
entire body as the spirit would no
longer be considered part of our world
it's believed they would have access to
the past present and future raising them
physically is something we see from
those who perhaps wish to bring a loved
one back from their dead or in some
cases their even used as a weapon to do
the bidding of their master
the word itself originated from the
Latin necromantic which was taken from
the Greek necrometal or necrometal which
meant divination by the means of a dead
body this takes us to some of the
earliest accounts of necromancy which
took place in Greece and Rome along with
Egypt and Babylonia and these practices
are often compared to shamanism and
there was no stigma or notion of
wrongdoing when it came to necromancy
and this is something that came much
later there was a practice in ancient
Greece called negiah or a Nekia which
essentially was a rite or a ritual where
the dead would be called upon to answer
questions about the future one of the
earliest examples we have of this
particular kind of necromancy comes from
Homer's Odyssey where we see the
powerful sorceress Circe who is capable
of both the raisin and communion with
the dead Circe then teaches many of
these spells to Odysseus the hero of the
story
she then advises him to travel to the
underworld and to perform an echo in
order to gather the information needed
for him to safely return home in book 11
of Homer's Odyssey Odysseus was
instructed to raise the spirit of the
blind prophet Tiresias and this
particular ritual is described in some
detail he must first light a fire in the
dark of night and then sacrifice animals
whose blood will be given to the shades
or spirits to drink whilst doing this he
would recite the incantations given to
him by Circe Odysseus encounters several
spirits before seeing the Prophet the
most notable of these being his mother
who he was shocked to see because he
believed that she was still alive when
tiresias finally appears he drinks the
blood and begins to give a discus the
information needed to make it home first
it wise in him not to eat the cattle of
Apollo to avoid incurring his wrath he
also tells him that he will return home
alone with none of his crew
we can see from this particular example
that necromancy wasn't seen as an evil
form of magic almost quite the opposite
this type of necromancy would be used by
numerous Greek and Roman poets who would
include these rituals in their stories
it became somewhat of a common trope for
Greek and Roman heroes to perform a
quatre basis a physical journey to the
underworld that involved performing a
task or a quest in many cases communion
with the dead those bringing the dead
back to life were referred to as
necromancer's and it seemed when it came
to summon in one's body they would
mainly focus on those who had died
recently within a year or two rituals of
necromancy did tend to vary as we saw in
Homer's Odyssey they can be quite a task
involving animal sacrifice and sometimes
even mutilation and consumption of the
dead
other times involves practices such as
wearing the clothing of the deceased and
consuming food such as blackened bread &
unfermented grape juice which was
thought to symbolize the decay and
lifelessness of death it was fairly
common practice to see artifacts such as
talismans and ones used alongside these
incantations so when did necromancy
become this dark heart and this school
of magic that was considered
unacceptable or taboo most sources point
to once a time period of medieval Europe
when the church really began to crack
down on magic and witchcraft
necromancy was one of those practices to
be condemned as dangerous the church
labeled the act of necromancy as
maleficium an act of witchcraft were the
intention of doing harm
necromancy would be equated to raising
demons who hid under the guise of
spirits
and the church believed that
resurrection itself was an act that
could only be performed with the
assistance of God and interestingly
enough there were a number of clergy who
did perform certain degrees of
necromancy these practitioners were
almost always highly trained and
educated in astrology demonology and
exorcism combined in the Christian
Jewish and Arabic teachings that
centered around necromancy practitioners
of necromancy or necromancer's outlined
three things they believed could be
achieved through the practice knowledge
illusion and the ability to manipulate
the will of others these three things
can all be seen in a positive and a
negative light it just comes down to
where you stand on one side you have the
church who believed those outside would
use necromancy as a means to harm others
and benefit themselves and those who are
not associated of the church saw it as
an attempt to control and limit this
form of magic so that it would only
benefit the church now whether or not
you believe these rituals and this
particular school of magic is real is
completely up to you my stance on the
currency is pretty much the same as my
stance on the supernatural and all sorts
of myths and legends I don't personally
believe in these stories but I believe
they created and inspired interesting
ideas and archetypes that we used and
still use today in storytelling and that
segues nicely onto the next part of the
video having discussed what necromancy
is where it came from and how it's
changed we can now take a look at some
more modern examples and how the
archetype of a necromancer is used today
for those of you who have been watching
this video and waiting for examples of
necromancer's there are quite a few that
appear in big franchises that you likely
would have heard of or seen before one
that many of us would have come across
in recent times is Tolkien's character
Sauron the Dark Lord who went by many
titles one of these of course being the
necromancer those who have watched the
movies and maybe read some of the books
may be wondering why he was given this
title because raising the dead isn't
something we really see in any of the
movies however in the history of
middle-earth a series of volumes
collected by Tolkien son from all of his
father's manuscripts in volume 10
morgoth's ring we see a quote that tells
us he is indeed capable of communion
with a dead enslaving them and harness
in their knowledge if we take a look at
the Mortal Kombat franchise we have
Shang Tsung and Quan Shi hoo both
assumed roles of warlocks and sorcerers
who dabble in the art of necromancy in
both their cases they focus on raising
the dead to form armies for their master
and ultimately do their bidding raising
an army of undead is honestly something
that we see from most necromancer's in
Harry Potter we of course have Lord
Voldemort a wizard who did practice
necromancy raising an entire army of
skeletons and zombies during the first
wizard in war which consisted mostly of
those he had already murdered we also
see something similar to this with the
white walkers and the knight king of
Game of Thrones who can raise the dead
by simply lifting his arms now all of
these examples so far definitely have
even intentions and they are the
villains of their respected stories but
as we've already seen necromancy wasn't
always considered a dark art and not all
necromancer's are depicted as evil we've
already discussed the story of Odysseus
who is the hero of Homer's Iliad and the
Odyssey if we take a look at the Marvel
Universe and black panther and specific
T'Challa sister Shuri has the ability to
reanimate the dead and she's no villain
we also have the rather interesting
example of dr. Frankenstein who many
consider to be a necromancer who
certainly didn't have evil intent I do
find the case of dr. Frankenstein to be
quite strange because technically you
can argue
that he did raise the dead and therefore
he qualifies as a necromancer but I tend
to look at him as more of a man of
science and he's monster as a creation
so I guess we do have to ask ourselves
other than the influence of the church
during the medieval period why are so
many necromancer's in fiction evil I
think it comes down to the fact that
they just make really good villains when
you defeat the villains army you expect
the battle or the war to be over but
with necromancer's they're capable of
summoning entire new armies from the
corpses given this feeling of
hopelessness they also have a level of
knowledge obtained through communing
with the dead that makes them more than
just a formidable enemy and there is
also this taboo when it comes to messing
of the dead and just leaving them to
rest in peace
thus the act of raising the dead can be
seen as disrespectful and even evil in
some cases there are some aspects of
necromancy that we don't always have to
view through a lens of ill intent such
as communicating with a dead I mean sure
let us than an aspect that can be used
in a negative way but someone wanting
closure for a close friend or a loved
one is something that most of us can
relate to how you choose to view
necromancy is ultimately your choice but
hopefully this video has been
informative I'm sure those of you who
are unfamiliar with the necromancy
archetype will start to notice it a lot
more in your favorite stories but feel
free to share your favorite
necromancer's or even just your thoughts
with me in the comments below
as always I have been your host
mythology and fiction explained
[Music]